[Music]
[Applause]
Shan Solsbury former NFL USC quarterback
host of the Shan Solsbury show on Sports
Talk 790 in
Houston good morning Sean uh man how we
doing buddy how are you my man are you a
USC apologist
today I'm still stuck on the the dumbass
fair catch call that the refs made they
got it wrong yeah um no I'm not
apologist Dan this Ain the last time
they're going to lose this year M what
they got a Oregon still Washington
Washington and UCLA yeah UCLA's got
really good defense and Team Speed
Washington can score from the tailgate
you know on meet Friday on The Dan
Patrick Show and we know how good Oregon
is Dan when you play offense like that
but can't get stops on defense at the
most critical times I'm not apologizing
for them I I thought their defense would
be better and Alex Grinch would have
them better they've lost physicality in
the interior and that's been going on
for a minute but you can't keep winning
games 48-44 this won't be their last
loss and Utah always manhandles them
physical physically and I think Kyle
Whittingham outside of Nick Sav the best
college football coach on the planet
yeah yeah High Praise but you know he's
done a great job and he's beaten USC I
think that's what regularly you know
four consecutive times there but I'm
watching the final drive and and maybe
this is piling on Caleb Williams but
he's on the bench and your defense is
out there like be involved and it didn't
feel like I don't know there's just an
indifference there that it's it's kind
of strange and I said this two weeks ago
uh as a friend of mine who's a NFL
scouty said look they're not a good team
Caleb Williams covers up a lot of this
but they're really not if you look at
the totality of the team they're not
threatening for a national championship
he said people think they are they're
not and he said said I wouldn't be
surprised if they end up with
four is it'll cover up for a lot of
weaknesses and it's not just defensively
I mean they got some but they also have
some physical as far as domination
weaknesses he bails you out all the time
which when one guy's that good and it's
the quarterback in a quarterback driven
League at every level Now High School
College Pro we automatically think
they're a great team they're not a great
team they're a good team with a great
talent but I also know what you're
talking about I try to guard against Dan
I do because I think the guy's a special
player I try to guard against the
disinterest look in the Optics of does
he care because remember they used to
say that about Eli Manning remember Dan
the shoulder shrug he doesn't care wins
two Super Bowl so I'm I'm trying not to
be the guy and but I I I'm with you I'm
thinking man is is is is he ready to
move on is this is he bored with this
knowing that if he doesn't make a play
they can't win and it's true if he plays
average they just won't win they won't
even be in a game so you think he could
shut it down could he shut it could he
shut it down this season oh gosh I I
would hope that would Dan that would
validate how people are what people what
you're saying right now about the
disinterest not up on the sidelines I
know that's been his routine regularly
sitting there with his head back and
looking up so um and I'm not apologizing
for me I don't like the Optics of it but
I also know when the guy's been that
good what else am I going to complain
about even though I'll try to find
something with USC football but he may
be Dan if you'd asked that question a
decade ago we'd have looked to you like
what do you mean shut it down nobody
shuts it down but we're at a time now
name image and likeness protect that or
there's money uh first pick or second
pick of the draft whatever it might be
maybe Dan I I I'll tell you what as a
teammate that would drive me fraking
crazy if it did I especially with the
three games they got to play now if it's
a bad bowl game You're Gonna Leave don't
play in it I get it when I say bad not a
January One Bowl game I I understand but
I hope he doesn't shut it down because
that would validate what a lot of people
want to believe that he's disinterested
even though if he's disinterested
imagine how good a player he'd be if he
was interested but they're they're a
decent team they don't threaten anybody
in the and there's three or four teams
in the Pack 12 outside of him uh
carrying them that are better than the
Trojans yeah I got the odds to win the
Heisman and Caleb Williams is not in
there anymore JJ McCarthy is tops then
Michael Pennock Jr Jaden Daniels Jordan
Travis and Dylan Gabriel and Dan you
need that Heisman moment right now I
think M somebody had asked me yesterday
and when I was talking to fritzy last
night I McCarthy to me is is the number
one choice as well it was all packed 12
Jaden Daniels has played well but again
they don't play defense you start to
look around the country and say okay
well then who is it it's no longer the
Pack 12 Bo Nicks hanging around with the
accuracy pennick had his moment where he
I don't know if he lost it but fell off
a little bit against Arizona State Drake
may had his moment Caleb Williams had
his against Notre Dame moment meaning
where they fall off McCarthy hasn't had
that yet and he's going to get his
Heisman moment when they play Ohio State
in what will be a huge game and a few
more McCarthy is the number one choice
he protects the ball and he kills you
more ways than one I actually think
Michigan is as complete a team as we
have in football right now and that
includes Georgia are they great no
really good I don't think we have a
great team agree I I I think that with
with Kirby Smart in the way they recruit
and the way they develop and teach at
Georgia there's no doubt they're really
good but I still think offensively I'm
not sold yet that Georg is that dominant
can go score 40 against a great defense
although I know know how good they are
and we know and I think when you lose
that many defensive players on Georgia
it's hard to overcome year after year I
don't think we have a great team in
college football and I think the eighth
team in the country can win the national
championship I think Washington could go
win the national title if played right
but as far as complete and really good
and a quarterback can can beat you more
ways than one Michigan's as good as we
got in the country Sean Solsbury former
NFL USC quarterback host of the Shan
Solsbury show you can hear that on
Sports Talk 790 in Houston the the worst
loss of the weekend if I said the bills
against the Patriots the Lions against
the Ravens other who had the worst
loss I I don't think it was the Lions
because this is about two or three of
these I expected this year from them
they're good for this where you go and
say what are you doing I think it was
more impressive on Baltimore side and I
also don't think it was the worst loss
because I actually think Detroit can run
away and hide in this division but with
buffalo battl in Miami who got there
from Philly last night um and we know
bich che's defense always shows up I
think that was the most impressive point
and I was doing a show yesterday Dan I
you know when you're gambling or you're
talking about point spreads I thought
New England would get inside the number
I just didn't think they'd beat him but
they were impressive that was their best
offensive performance as far as I'm
concerned of M Jones protecting the ball
I'm gonna go with Buffalo because
Buffalo now validates what we keep
thinking great talent uh when are they
going to close this out when are they
going to do what Kansas City does when
are they going to be new New England
when Brady was there where they got all
this skill set can they dominate you
running it can they can they handle
typical and constant success I think
that was it's tough to go to New England
and win but to me that was the one
because that's going to be a much
tighter division than the than the
Detroit Lions in the uh NFC North it'll
come down to the last week or two in in
in that division in the AFC East the the
NFC North will be won in early in early
December by the Lions explain to me how
Travis Kelce you you know what he's
going to do and they still couldn't stop
him knowing what he was going to do
right how does that happen you know your
game planning for Travis Kelce right
yeah Dad what what did the bellich
approach or anybody I'm not letting your
best beat me not name the quarterback
and guess with the best every week he
beats you and I you know it helps that
they got a play caller that knows how to
deploy him and motion him and Andy Reid
and put him in positions the thing
that's most baffling to me and go back
and look like in the playoff game and
that game against Buffalo when they were
back and forth and in Super Bowls Dan I
don't know why people give him such a
free run off the line of scrimmage you
know how in basketball like the the the
the Bulls would bring in like will
Purdue LC they have like three guys for
six fouls you had 18 to give I don't
know why we don't Maul him at the line
of scrimmage even in motion I know you
back off a little but take your foul go
clutch and grab you cannot give him free
reign I want to make him work more at
the line of scrimmage than I do in space
you give him in space it's the old
choice out okay if they play an inside
man run away play an outside man you run
away inside in zone stretch the outside
leverage of the zone and sit and then
Mahomes and him are just playing
schoolyard even though it's designed
well it's like go down there to the car
make a left behind Dan's Mercedes and
stand there and we'll throw it to you
and that's the way it works but I don't
get in professional sports how I don't
care if you're doubling him like you do
the Gunner on the or the the you know
guy covering punts you can't let the
best player at his position in the world
have free and just when we think Kansas
City's offense are they the same Mahomes
still goes and throws for 400 yards you
cannot let that guy it'd be like saying
hey let's give Derrick Henry in his
Prime when he's running 40 carries and
just open up a hole for him you got to
stop the team's best and make somebody
else beat you for some reason I guess
it's harder than than we describe
because nobody seems to be able to do it
help me understand what's going on with
the Browns and Deshawn
Watson I don't know Dan I I'm I'm
bothered by it though I'm bothered by it
because I think winning teammates over
matters and I don't know how they feel
in the locker room about him I know from
a distance we speak of Optics on Caleb
Williams the Optics don't look good the
Optics do not look good I I don't like
it when a guy's pronounced fit and
doesn't play and then when he goes and
plays now I don't know how severely he
was hurt all that but you could make the
easy case that you say well he got paid
got the bag so he's taking time off and
load management fits him like it does
the NBA it bothersome I don't think
deshun Watson's ever going to put his
team in position to win a Super Bowl
again um I know why he's easy to root
against if you're some people he's an
enormous talent and the Browns are
really good but I like what PJ Walker
did I I don't know and Dan you know this
it gets to a certain point if you're not
running through a wall running jumping
over a wall or going around a wall for
that guy your quarterback and maybe they
still are then you got a problem and
this team is a playoff team with Super
Bowl aspirations and and I I don't know
what's going on but there's a disconnect
yeah and I just don't know where it is
and if deshun Watson I'll ask simply
does he still love playing football that
I don't know and I don't know where the
level of his pain tolerance is it
doesn't look good Optics wise and
especially when the guy who comes in is
winning games for you and they only owe
him $190 million guaranteed the next
three years so that shouldn't be a
problem no he'll be okay I mean I mean
you know but who's counting Dan why I
mean who's keeping score right
yeah
over the next three years right and
there's a good chance he may not be the
one quarterback in him in February he
can get you to January we still wonder
if he can get you to February but
there's got to be the the passion and
love for it I always ask quarterbacks
when they come to me young I say to
their parents they say does he love to
play he loves to play fine and that
exists all the way through to the end
and I'm assuming Deshawn loves to play
but there is some kind of Disconnect and
the Optics look
horrible the
uh you know the brotherly show of the
push tush um it works it works too well
and sometimes it feels like the extra
point before they moved it back like you
know it's boring automatic um can if
you're on the competition committee and
they ask for your vote is the push tush
in play next
year uh no and here's why Dan here's why
my excuse would be if I was on that
committee is one is you know how we
always say hey let's air on the side of
protecting football players we want to
protect them yet I can think of nothing
worse for a quarterback other than
getting hit in the back of the head
Blind Side is having guys that outweigh
you a thousand pounds pushing you from
behind while the others are coming and
if they hit you high and you're getting
pushed low that'll bin back it's a blown
knee weai the first time a star blows
out his knee if it was Herz or somebody
else that rule goes away hell they'll
have an emergency meeting to canc but
Sean the Eagles are choosing to do this
right exactly right and the rules L them
so they got bulldozer behind them
pushing them and they but the second
Jaylen Herz hey man my lower back feels
like a disc went down into my hamstring
then it'll change but right now the rule
says go for it and they're really damn
good at it but to me it I don't care if
it's boring boring football sometimes
wins games we've seen that a lot but
when it comes to this if you're actually
airing on the side of protecting the
player which we do so often in this
league and overboard maybe just maybe
that you would want to think about that
too but if you notice Dan the only time
we really want to protect the players is
when it's a head shot we don't really
care about their knees or their lower
back or their shoulders we care about
the head but un I hated the quarterback
sneak anyway because people are always
flying at your head with that now you
got people pushing people pulling the
whole thing yeah I I would say that
that's not long for the NFL but right
now if you're the Eagles you do it well
use it why wouldn't you if you're not
afraid to thanks bud good to talk to you
appreciate you Astros tonight brother
should be a good one man can somebody
get somebody out that'd be nice at Home
cast tonight can a home team win a game
there you go thanks brother I appreciate
you Shan Salsbury former NFL USC
quarterback